two bottles of vodka
is this gonna be the weekend we finally
meet six drink amy six drink amy what
does that mean it's the pinnacle of the
santiago drunkenness scale one drink
amy's a little spacey wait what
two drinks loud amy you want to get a
cab
three drinks amy dance pants
poor drink amy is a bit of a pervert hey
check it out
and five drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man
but i've never seen six drink amy maybe
she's the one i could actually be
friends with aka
my sasquatch
so cold even my fiery dance moves aren't
keeping me warm the trick is you gotta
be prepared
mini cognac lady oh
yeah
warm me up you little bastard
more drinks
thank you terry's fanny and thank you
poseidon boyle rosa and amy you're up
come on get on it and under it bangarang
damn sam
you don't want to be around holt in your
current state
say hello to the most confident woman
alive
uh
drink number five
you
are a true friend
and a hot little piece
goodbye forge rank amy sloppy sicko
six drink amy
so alone oh no
sex drink amy isn't fine she's just sad
damn it aims gina
you got to see the sasquatch was it
everything you dreamt it was the stuff
drums are made of can you hold my eyes
still till things stop spinning okay
let's set you up air easy there oh there
you go now drink this entire glass of
water
you're taking care of me just because i
know you won't remember it
nope
you like me
six drink amy is your friend
and and she's
gonna be very sick right now okay i
guess it would have to be channing
tatum's body ryan gosling's face
and michael fassbender's
sense of humor what about you build your
perfect guy um
yao ming's torso
napoleon's brain and the hunchback of
notre dame's hunchback
do you like my nails
even though she hides it underneath
layers of sarcasm resentment and
grumpiness i know deep down somewhere
april likes me
i'm kind of just fracking for friendship
are you ready for you to tell me what's
going on with chris yes no to sing
if you're lost you can look and you will
find me
time after time go no tell me about
chris if you fall i will catch you i'll
be waiting tell me about chris or i'm
leaving and i don't care about the
letter
i want to have a baby and i asked chris
to donate his sperm and he's taking a
really long time to make up his mind and
it's really freaking me out and i can't
stop thinking about it and i'm obsessing
about it i want to think about anything
else but that but it's making me crazy
secrets
stolen
from deep inside you know the song
already of course i do everyone knows
the song it's amazing the drum beats out
of time if you're lost you can look and
you will find me
time after time
if you fall i will catch you oh i'll be
waiting
time after time
time after time
time after time
this never happened
i'm on my phone and rose is just sitting
there silently the usual well i was
thinking we could have a lady's lunch
today amy i wish i could do lunch today
but i'm currently out of town oh come on
i want to hang out one last time before
you before you leave us you're really
special gina and even though
i'm sorry i just get so emotional about
these things you know i wish i could be
more like rosa huh i got bored what's
going on see she doesn't even give a
damn i wish i could do that then i would
cry less at the bank it's just there's
this one poster of this older asian man
opening a savings account for his
grandson okay all right here's what's
gonna happen amy santiago as my parting
gift to you before i leave your life
forever we'll still see each other
outside of work before i leave your life
forever i'm gonna fix you i'm gonna
teach you how to be more cool and
detached like me and rosa what's going
on but we could still go to lunch right
i mean or not
whatevs decent start yeah sure i mean
we'll go to lunch with you why not okay
okay cool just before we go i'm gonna go
to the bathroom for a bit not to cry
about you leaving but just to
take a huge dump so if you hear any
crying from the bathroom
it's not about you
it's the dump okay
yippee
road trip who's excited to go to
bloomington is that where you're gonna
sit
i'm driving where else would i sit trunk
i helped april get into vet school in
bloomington and today's her orientation
so we're taking a little road trip while
i'm there i'm also gonna pick up an
organic baby blanket i would get one of
pawnee but fun fact our only baby store
is attached to a chemical refinery
i made a special road trip mix cd for us
i hope you like toriyamus oh cool
all right so you have everything you
need for orientation yeah
an empty sprite can an old man's
fingernail in my pocket and a picture of
patrick ewing on a roller coaster i'm
all set right
hi you're back hello again
as you remember i'm april and this is
anne my 65 year old grandmother
yes that's who i am anyway we'd love to
hear about bloomington it seems like a
real hip kind of college town me ma god
no one uses the word hip anymore
sometimes i wish you went down on the
titanic with all your sorority sisters
i'm not going to school here april don't
flake out on this you're going to love
it here bloomington is great it's got
culture and music and tons of youngsters
youngsters
am i 65 years old yeah i'm not going
here i don't want to let's leave
can we please talk about what happened
back there what ann i just stole your
phone and texted every guy in it that
the baby was there it's not that big of
a deal listen i know you don't believe
this but i care about your future
and i'm just a little disappointed that
you're just not following through with
this yeah it's not about following
through
okay i was on the fence about whether i
wanted to do it and as soon as i got
there i just
had a gut feeling that it wasn't right
for me that's all so just like that boom
huge life decision made that's how i
make all my life decisions my gut is
always right okay
it was right about marrying andy and it
was right when it told me that you would
be the worst person i would ever meet in
my life
and i've met guy fieri and
so gross
how do you get your gut to talk to you
you don't get your gut to talk to you
you just listen when it says something
well
right now my gut is saying that we are
going to listen to mariah carey the
whole way home
good
[Music]
gina since you're leaving i'd like to
make a toast
bye oh my god that was perfect so nice
gina i got a little going-away present
for you don't worry it's nothing big
oh my goodness wow you once said if you
ever die you wanted someone to turn your
tweets into a book so that's what i did
oh my god i said so many witty things so
fast yeah
amy i don't know what to say this is
horrifying what this is way worse than
crying i mean you put so much work into
this i'm completely uncomfortable it
makes me
kind of makes me sick amy there's
something i want you to do right now
burn the book i need you yes it's the
only way to cleanse your childish
sentimentality and become the true you
the one that's really rosa
okay
sure
i mean it does include a very personal
forward i wrote and 75 of my best
archival glue but
yeah this feels good hey never seen you
burning stuff with a bum barrel before
right on
what was in there hitchcock
first rule of the bun barrel never ask
somebody what they're burning well okay
then
all right amy it's time put the book in
the barrel let's go
no i can't do it what i thought you
wanted us to change you i thought i did
too but i don't i like having emotions
okay this is who i am
you're leaving and that's a really big
change and i'm gonna cry about it a lot
okay and there it is another flawless
gina moment what what's going on amy the
lesson i wanted to leave you with is to
just be yourself if you want to cry like
an idiot for hours on end just do it you
want to make a big old ugly book full of
all my brilliant thoughts do it
do you
it's gina
oh wow
that was really really sweet oh dip i
got rosa to feel her feelings too
inadvertent gina moment two for one
come in my babies come in
sorry to interrupt ladies but you might
want to take a couple of steps back this
is not gonna smell good
my going away present to you
will be that i do not make you audibly
say
that you love me
thank you
okay leslie's coming back get off me
wench did i miss a nice moment no yes
you did
[Music]
you